[Laughter]
the final movies in harry potter may
have been more on the intense side as
far as filming goes but that doesn't
mean it isn't without its bloopers and
ridiculous antics behind the scenes
number one emma watson stole some hair
from harry potter himself
iconic
don't they give you wigs for this kind
of stuff
either way we admire emma for her
tenacity number two you've got some
nerve to call harry potter hideous
bill
look away
i'm idiots
i look fantastic in women's clothing it
isn't as easy as the movies make it look
hey dan number three rupert grint took a
trip to nowhere nice
he stumbled over a log and hermione
tried to comfort him over his
embarrassment because apparently he
tripped with style the most amazing like
james bond style rubert's having none of
it hit it at quite a pace and then just
sort of flopped over it if he needs a
good excuse he can just say his
character would trip over the log
perfect casting confirmed number four
there are worse ticks than corpsing on
camera
emma watson's always been a giggler but
the stress of staying in the moment and
pretending a creepy snake is about to
pop out at her set her over the edge
we should give her some credit first off
pretending you're about to be lunged at
by a giant scary snake is tough adding
on the layer of the crew attempting to
jump scare her by yelling snake is just
plain unfair
number five the whole place is falling
apart is this why they didn't use this
shot
oops quick blame it on rupert
what we can't get over is how dan went
in intending to break the thing that's
not the face of an innocent man was the
set designed to break if not he knows
it's a set right the things aren't
always sturdy keep your hands to
yourself number six it's gotta sting
when a beautiful woman is giggling at
the idea of kissing you we don't care if
you're just good friends seriously is it
just us or is rupert looking a bit
offended by just how giggly emma is
about their kiss
what did rupert have to apologize for we
need to know
and how about that big celebration after
they landed the shot
at least daniel wasn't in the room
making the situation worse
everyone was there for my kiss yeah emma
wait what guy wants to be around
watching his friends awkwardly smooch
over and over again take a day treat
yourself number seven rupert's like a
bowl in a china shop
rupert may play a keeper in quidditch
but in this case he's a quaffle
sounds like rupert was the weasley on
and off screen
number eight as much fun as helena
bonham carter seems we'd rather act
alongside literally anybody else no
offense helena if you're watching this
we would just prefer our internal organs
stay on the inside she is notorious for
injuring her co-stars okay she did it
like twice from what we could gather not
only did she once perforate matthew
lewis's eardrum with a wand she also
whacked dany with a dagger
this may not be the cause of a magic
wand but emma watson still had a dizzy
spell
you can and you probably should if you
want to get through the rest of the day
number 10 in character or out of
character the weasleys like to have a
bit of fun
these two were the life of the simulated
party
number 11 rule 101 don't slurp your tea
around emma watson or no work will get
accomplished come on t isn't even that
funny
i'm so sorry
turns out emma is just a snooty tea
drinker who sits silently on her tea and
judges everyone else
[Music]
i don't know how you feel number 12.
when helena bonham carter goes off
script magic happens but sometimes that
magic is a bit too much
she doesn't need any more incentive for
chaos don't be afraid to go off script
number 13. michael gambin just showed up
here and talked a lot in like different
ways michael isn't doing a whole lot to
get into character for dumbledore he's
already dumbledore but he just amps up
the mysterious factor on camera
no the beard doesn't do it all for him
when we do the scene now again in a
minute i should change my it will be
played in a completely different way
gasp that almost sounds like acting
claim in the
[Music]
for reasons we aren't quite sure of
helena bonham carter adopted daniel
radcliffe come on get boy
this behavior on set seems a little
lestrange
here here okay it's my dog
[Laughter]
number 15 don't bring jokes to a wand
fight
[Music]
sounds like helena bonham carter was
able to make the weasley mama wheeze
black off boys
we bet it takes work to get under
molly's skin but bellatrix makes it look
so easy helena's character is akin to
the class clown and we've seen how molly
responds to fred and george acting like
clowns number 16 poor dan got stuck
repeating a line over and over again
it's almost like he's
filming a movie that line of variants of
that line is all i say for the last 45
minutes
apparently you're bad at killing snakes
kill the snake we've got to kill
anything we have to kill the thing we
get the idea and are you
going to get it right at some point
gonna go to lunch
burn radcliffe imagine being that guy
number 17 this was an i meant to do that
moment for sure alan rickman had very
very few bloopers in all of the harry
potter franchise
the man was a legend perfect on screen
and off except for this one moment
the delayed ow is what makes this moment
just hilarious
number 18 defeating voldemort is no
laughing matter his lack of a nose on
the other hand is
giggles is back again did we mention
emma was given the nickname giggles
although we're pretty sure she was
already messing up before the giggles
erupted you can see it in the way she
just accepted her defeat we'll go once
again number 19. there are literally tv
shows dedicated to racing dan and emma
must have gotten in the wrong line at
the casting calls daniel radcliffe and
emma watson were definitely the more
competitive of the trio of actors
they're all going to say to the fastest
i am anytime they got a chance to run on
screen the two made a challenge of it
them said emma probably
she's wrong i'm faster now the
competition was getting so out of hand
they got a wee little reprimand from the
director and emma was told she needed to
slow down to get the shot right this
scene is about the film not about which
one of you can run the fastest and
literally everybody knows rupert isn't
the fastest even he does rupert knows
he's not the fastest
number 20. tom felton was not prepared
for his instincts to betray him so much
the worst part about doing a hard stunt
wrong is doing it again
[Music]
tom felton can't not anticipate the drop
from the table the look in their faces
that is genuine honestly it's one thing
to do a stunt from a rig that looks like
it was built for the scene it's another
to rely on a very real looking pile of
junk to drop you to the floor we gotta
say we're on tom's side it looks
absolutely terrifying now that it's been
over 10 years looking back on these
silly moments has us longing to re-watch
the series and while they were doing
their best to stay serious on set they
found the best way to entertain
themselves on their breaks the second
ever but first outdoors danger ball 2009
champion
what's the goofiest thing you've ever
done at your job let us know in the
comments and thanks for hanging out with
us here at the things